(electronic music)
- [Narrator] B-boys, breakdancers,
whatever you wanna call them:
If you're looking for the best,
look no further than South Korea.
(crowd cheers)
(electronic music)
These dancers aren't just popular,
they're influencing culture
throughout the country.
(hip-hop music)
(mellow electronic music)
(electronic beat)
This is B-boy Skim and this is B-boy Wing.
And they're brothers.
(mellow electronic music)
They're members of the Jinjo Crew,
one of the best break
dancing groups in the world.
Let's break down some moves.
The basics start with a tap
rack, or the opening dance.
Then, you move to footwork,
where the dancer's supported
only by their hands or feet.
Footwork builds into flow techniques
and flow techniques
build up to power moves,
like the flair and the head spin.
These moves take years to master.
(crowd cheers)
(dance music)
(slow dance music)
(electronic chime note)